well let's go to ukraine now where the
country's defense minister alexi
rezanovko says that a force of one
million people is being pulled together
to help in the fight against russia well
joining me now for his analysis of the
situation is the defense and security
analyst professor michael clark and it's
great to have you here with us um
professor so one million really is that
realistic
uh in the longer run it probably is not
immediately because the ukrainians are
it's a country of 44 million people
and they have got a reserve force in
which 300 000 of them of the almost a
million in the reserves have served in
the donbass in recent years they've got
an army of 125 000 so i mean i reckon
that they've got a potentially an army
of about 400 000 troops which is a lot
more than the russians have got there
and they can probably arm other people
they wouldn't wouldn't all be soldiers
but there'd be border guards militia uh
different internal security people so
yes it's it's plausible what reznikov
was really getting at i think is saying
that we have ambitions to liberate the
south of the country the ukrainians are
already pushing quite a big offensive
incursion we may see some real really
dramatic events there in the next couple
of weeks but eventually he's saying we
will liberate the south part of the
country what it really reflects is the
fact that come the autumn if the
ukrainians can hang on then the pendulum
will begin to swing back towards them
militarily on present trends if the
russians don't do something pretty
dramatic then the pendulum will swing
against russian forces and towards
ukrainian forces now looking at events
last week russia managed to successfully
take the luhansk region is that momentum
likely to continue
well in the long run it probably is in
the next couple of months but the
russians never take an area and then
keep on moving they have to take and
stop and take and stop that's what they
do partly because they rely so much on
artillery and they've got to get their
artillery pieces into a new position and
they seem to need to be able to take a
rest they're not very good at
maintaining momentum we always we
thought they would be but they haven't
by and large the ukrainians are falling
back towards slaviansk and kramatos just
south of slaviansk those are the big
strategic targets and there's a couple
of other cities mean bakmut um and
subversting
on the way to slavians will be very
important waypoints and we'll see how
that develops but it won't develop over
the next couple of days more likely to
be the next couple of weeks and in the
meantime what the ukrainians are doing
they're using their rockets that they've
got now from america from britain from
other countries they're long-distance
rockets to target
russian uh ammunition bases and um
command centers and they've put a lot of
targets together in this whole area
particularly of donetsk and in fact
they've they seem to have reduced
russian ammunition stocks quite
considerably because the russians given
that they operate in a more centralized
way have got ammunition stocks in known
places they can't disperse them very
well the ukrainians know where they are
and now they can target them fairly
accurately so there's been a series of
strikes over the last few days which
have been quite dramatic we'll see what
difference it makes ultimately but the
ukrainians are trying to slow the
russian advance down
long enough for the pendulum to swing
back in their favor which it probably
will towards the end of the summer early
autumn professor michael clark always
great to get your analysis thank you